.
>> ALLEN LAID OUT YOUR
ACCOLADES.
TIM SAID YOU ARE A HALL OF
FAMER.
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHY UTAH WAS
WILLING TO TRADE YOU.
>> THAT IS A GOOD QUESTION.
OBVIOUSLY LOSING QUIN, HE WAS
THERE FOR EIGHT YEARS, A BIG
PART OF WHAT WE WERE DOING.
SOMETIMES THE WINDOW FOR WINNING
IS NOT ALWAYS BIG.
FOR US IN UTAH, THAT IS KIND OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
I THINK THE ORGANIZATION FELT
LIKE WE HAD MAY BE PAST THAT
WINDOW WE HAD OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS, AND I THINK THIS WILL BE
A VERY COMPETITIVE TEAM BUT THEY
FELT LIKE WITH ALL THE ASSETS
THEY COULD GET WITH ME, IT WAS
BETTER FOR THEM TO GO THAT WAY.
I THINK IT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
A WIN-WIN SITUATION.
THEY ALSO PUT ME IN A GREAT
SITUATION TO WIN, AND FOR ME
THAT IS WHAT I AM GRATEFUL FOR.
THEY PUT